Comment allez vous les amis aujourd'hui moi ça va très bien. Ça va si bien qu'aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous raconter des choses !
La dernière fois je vous avais raconté des anecdotes sur le jeu de mon enfance Dofus et ça vous avez carrément plu ! Aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter des anecdotes sur mon adolescence !
Tout d'abord je vais vous parler d'une chose incroyable de mon adolescence...  Le PC.
En 2011 je faisais déjà des vidéos sur ma chaîne youtube et du coup, j'adorai être devant les écrans, je jouais tout le temps aux  jeux vidéo je regardais tout le temps la télévision
Enfin la télévision c'est à dire Game One parce qu'il passait les animés,  j'adorais les animés et c'est tout, le problème c'est que ma mère n'était pas d'accord avec ça
elle n'aimait pas me voir regarder la télévision
Donc elle me bridait ! Elle me donnait des heures auxquelles j'avais le droit d'accéder au PC et une fois l'heure passé je dégageais !
À l'époque je vivais dans une maison où il y avait un sous sol et un étage et le PC se trouvait au sous-sol  !
Donc de 18 à 19 heures j'allais au sous-sol jouer au PC et ensuite j'avais plus le droit d'en faire ma mère voulait pas mettre de pc dans ma chambre
et à juste titre sinon j'aurai totalement fait des nuits blanches et j'aurais raté toutes mes années scolaires mais ce qu'elle savait pas c'est que
le soir quand ma mère était plongée dans un sommeil lourd
Le petit Lucas sortait en cachette de sa chambre en pyjama... Et qu'est ce qu'il faisait... ? Il allait aux toilettes
et lorsqu'il tirait la chasse d'eau, il profitait du bruit de cette dernière pour descendre les marches en toute discrétion
marches en bois qui font donc un maximum de bruit
Donc je jouais comme ça à Dofus comme ça pendant des heures et des heures et des fois suspense
j'entendais quelqu'un descendre des marches et là je me disais putain option A c'est mon frère, je m'en bats les couilles !
Option B c'est ma mère, je suis mort ! Dans cette pièce y avait une sorte de placard aménagé
dans lequel il y avait la chaudière et qu'est ce que je faisais quand ma mère descendais ? Je me cachais derrière la chaudière comme une
bonne merde
mais j'étais très con parce que vu que j'étais pas dans ma chambre je pouvais être qu'à un seul endroit.  Lucas, je sais que t'es là !
Non ! Je sais que t'es là ! Y'a personne ! Tu  est privé de PC pendant sept jours ! Non !!!
C'était la mission chaque soir mais ce qui est cool c'est que j'arrivais généralement à gratter quelques heures de PC du coup toutes les nuits.
Donc au final c'était une très bonne période parce que vous allez voir que ce qui va suivre c'est beaucoup moins amusant ! Hé hé !
Quelques années plus tard ma mère a accepté de mettre un PC dans ma chambre !
Le fait est que ma mère avait aussi mis un mot de passe sur l'ordi que je ne connaissais pas
Donc quand je voulais faire de l'ordi,  fallait que je lui demande...
Et comme ma mère adorait le chantage elle me disais...  Oui oui oui tu as fait tes devoirs tu as rangé sa chambre tu m'as
fait un virement de 500 euros sur mon compte
Mais maman j'ai pas d'argent chez que 15... Alors alors Lucas ! Une fois que j'avais fait toutes ces tâches
j'avais enfin le droit d'aller sur l'ordinateur ma mère venait elle taper le mot de passe j'ai trouvé une technique car j'étais un hacker
d'exception j'étais allé chez un pote et j'avais gravé sur un cd un truc qui permettait de trouver le mot de passe de ton ordi
un jour je mets le cd dans mon pc comme ça je lance le logiciel de
hacking, j'attends qu'ils fassent effet et il me donne le mot de passe de mon pc
guitare
C'qui est pas un mot de passe très sécurisé ! Du coup pendant des mois j'allais sur le pc quand je voulais sans que ma mère
le sache parce qu'elle ne se doutait pas que je connaissais le mot de passe.
En vrai je pense qu'elle s'en doutait un peu vu que le temps que je passais dans ma chambre avait été multiplié par 600 !
Et comme j'avais pas accès à leur dire je disais mais qu'est ce qui peut faire dans sa chambre lucas et je jouais tout le
temps sans son pour être à l'affût du moindre bruit parce que si elle ouvrait la porte et qu'elle me voyait sur l'ordi, elle allait comprendre
que je connaissais le mot de passe ! J'me souviens avec c'est tellement un vieux gars
J'prenais la chaise comme ça et je bloquais la poignée avec, tu sais j'faisais comme dans les films !
Ok ! Si ma mère arrive, la chaise va tomber, ça va faire du bruit et j'aurai le temps d'éteindre l'écran et  d'faire semblant de lire
un livre ! Ha !
Rassurez-vous,  j'ai jamais besoin d'en arriver là , j'étais, j'étais, j'étais malin mais pas aussi malin que ma mère !
Quelques années plus tard, ma mère
réfléchit à un nouveau processus lui permettant de contrôler mon temps passé sur les écrans, lorsqu'elle a une idée de génie
Engueuler son mari pour que lui il trouve ! Ha !
Chose qu'il a fait il est informaticien à mon beau-père
et
putain ! Il a été très ingénieux un jour ma mère vient sur l'ordi elle fait " Au fait Lucas, j'vais retirer le mot de passe
maintenant il ya un contrôle parental ce sera plus simple comme ça ça s'active à telle heure ça se coupe à telle heure et j'ai
pas besoin de venir mettre de mot de passe. Mais c'était pas un contrôle parental qu'elle avait mis c'était un contrôle de box mais un
contrôle de box au fait maison ! À 22h, le net coupe donc la première fois je suis surpris je fais "Quoi ?"
C'est le net qui coupe ? Je descends au rez-de-chaussée là où il y avait la box et là mec
je fais la découverte la plus traumatisante de toute ma vie mon père avait soudé un minuteur à la prise de courant sur lequel il
avait soudé l'alimentation de la freebox
je m'étais dit putain mais mec osef je vais acheter une deuxième alim de freebox et je débrancherait le cadre de la freebox
pour brancher une autre alim dessus je suis un génie c'était avant de découvrir que le câble relié à la freebox
était cadenassé. Voilà. C'est à dire que mon beau-père avait soudé un petit truc en fer et que le cadenas bloquait le câble et que
tu pouvais pas débrancher le câble. À partir de là j'étais définitivement
baisé !
Deuxième chose dont je vais vous parler, et ça c'est bizarre parce que ça concerne je pense que ma famille c'est la nourriture mec
Moi ma mère elle avait un problème avec les courses. C'est à dire quand elle en faisait c'était des petites courses pour pas que ça
coûte trop cher et quand on avait tous bouffés elle attendait un petit moment avant d'en refaire ce qui fait qu on mourait littéralement de
faim pendant plusieurs jours. Hé, hé, hé ! Du coup mon frère et moi dans cette maison il y avait un trésor qu'on voulait défendre coûte que coûte
Notre alimentation était essentiellement constitué le matin et au goûter de tranches de brioche avec du nutella. Élément perturbateur
le niveau du nutella
baissait chaque matin mais je veux dire chaque matin avant qu'on en prenne. Dans la nuit quoi ! Avec mon frère devenu parano j'avais même pensé
installer une caméra dans la cuisine pour voir qui bouffait et notre nutella dans notre dos ! Vous vous souvenez de ce que je vous ai dit
le pc était au sous sol quand quelqu'un descendait, je l'entendais la nuit ! Un jour quelqu'un descend les escaliers je me cache dans la chaudière
comme à mon habitude
en attendant que cette personne remonte les marches et retourne dans sa chambre. Mais au bout de dix minutes toujours rien,  je ne comprends pas je décide
alors d'aller au rez-de-chaussée voir ce qui se passe et on ouvrant la porte de la cuisine je découvre quelque chose qui me traumatisa à vie.
Ma mère accroupie en face du placard qui contenait le précieux nutella, se retourne une petite cuillère à la main mais surtout notre
précieux pot de nutella mais elle me regarde avec un regard bizarre en fait elle était somnambule et régulièrement dans son sommeil elle allait dans
la cuisine et elle mangeait du nutella mais sans s'en rendre compte le matin tu lui en parlait, elle savait pas puisqu'elle était somnambule
On avait le droit à un pot par semaine et elle, elle en mangé une partie. Vous pouvez rire mais,
ce corps, ce corps que j'ai aujourd'hui c'est en partie à cause de ça je n'ait pas pu le nourrir quand il en avait besoin
ok
Troisième chose dont je vous parlais dans cette vidéo c'est les bêtises que j'ai fait quand j'étais ado on en a tous fait des petites
bêtises ah on connaît bien alerte rouge squeezie et un gros thug il a fini une fois chez les flics
devinez pourquoi devinez pourquoi un truc de thug un truc vraiment vénère des flics on y voit ça y deviennent ouf ils t'arrêtes direct
Tu risque d'aller en prison et tout j'ai fait des pétards dans un parc fermé
énorme je sais, c'est énorme
je me souviens très bien les flics sont des gens
l'opération la plus ouf de leur carrière mon gars. Ils sont arrivés des deux côtés du parc
il nous embarquent dans la voiture de police mec. J'ai été embarqué dans une voiture de police une fois dans ma vie.
Je suis un putain de thug !
J'arrive au commissariat, ils appellent tous nos parents, nos parents viennent nous chercher ma mère arrive les flics le fond une morale de malade
Madame c'est vraiment pas bien ce qu'il a fait. Oui, oui je sais ! Mais madame vous rendez compte oui oui ok ! Ma mère m'a donc ramener
chez moi et j'ai eu aucune punition elle s'en foutait un peu parce que je faisais jamais de conneries que j'étais tout le temps sur
l'ordi je pouvais pas faire de bêtises dehors
J'étais en troisième et j'avais des dm de maths à faire chez moi. Une fois que les avait fait il fallait les scanner et les envoyer
via la messagerie
du collège à ta prof de maths. Le collège avait donc créé un compte par élève est ton pseudo c'était ton nom donc moi c'est
Hauchard, et ton mot de passe et à date de naissance donc moi c'était le 27 janvier
1996 mais du coup quand quelqu'un d'autre était née le même jour que toi ou quand t'avais Facebook simplement tu pouvais connaître la date de
naissance de tous tes potes et te connecter à leur compte sur la messagerie est de faire passer pour eux on se donne rendez vous
avec tous mes potes chez elle l'un d'eux qui s'appelle quentin ok on se connecte chacun notre messagerie on envoie tout nos DM
et là moi j'ai une idée de merde. Hé les mecs mathilde et même jour que moi je veux dire qu'on peut se connecter à
son truc et s'faire passer pour elle ! Ouais !  En plus elle est déléguée donc euh.. Oh putain !
On se connecte au compte de cette Mathilde et on décide d'envoyer un mail à notre prof de maths qui n'a rien à voir avec
un devoir maison donc on a écrit un mail qui insultait pas du tout la prof,  qui disait au contraire vous êtes vraiment
belle madame je vous ai vu à la sortie du collège la dernière fois et mon coeur s'est enflammé
J'aimerais un jour vous donner rendez vous dans un restaurant pour boire un verre tous les deux nous pourrions faire connaissance voire même allez un
petit peu plus loin
bisous sur la foufoune. Ce bisou sur la foufoune c'est ça qui va profondément nous faire du tort. Quatre jours plus tard on est en
cours de maths comme ça et le cpe vient chercher Quentin !
Merde ! Dix minutes plus tard le CPE vient
et il m'appelle moi !
Lucas. Alors je le suis comme ça et il m'amène dans le bureau du proviseur et qu'est ce que je trouve dans le bureau du
proviseur mon pote quentin littéralement en train de chialer sa grosse race
Mais vraiment ! Il a jamais chialer comme ça de toute sa vie c'est sûr et il me dit : Mais Lucas, on l'a fait ensemble ce
truc je veux pas être le seul à le prendre !
Oh, le bâtard ! Il m'avait totalement
balancé parce qu'il se tait chier dessus en vrai c'est moi qui avais eu l'idée donc d'un côté je le comprends totalement mais moi j'avoue
j'avais une sortie une sorte de code d'honneur au collège c'est faut pas balancer les potes tu vois, je sais pas, c'est marrant c'est comme ça et
ensuite le proviseur me dit : Bon Lucas, vous êtes le cerveau de l'opération
Tu sais, comme s'il parlait d'un braquage d'une banque mon gars on parle d'un mail, un canular ! Dites moi qui étais avec vous ce jour
là et moi je lâche rien pendant dix minutes ils essayent je lâche rien il y avait un autre prof de maths qui étaient là
et c'est lui qui avait mis au point qui avait codé la messagerie du collège et là il se prends pour moi
quand j'avais le
cd qui permet trouver le mot de passe de mon pc il fait : Écoutez Lucas c'est très simple vous vos 2 potes et quentin
avait envoyé vos devoirs sous la même adresse ip vous savez ce que c'est une adresse ip ? Hé, hé, hé !
il était tout fier de savoir ce qu'était une adresse ip le con. Eh bien ça tombe à Lucas car le mail de mathilde a été envoyé de
la même adresse ip. Là moi je suis à terre, je suis au sol je suis pas bien dans ma tête c'est vraiment, je me dit : putain non
je veux pas que mes potes tombent à cause de moi on va aller en prison
et là j'ai une idée et je dis ah mais c'est normal en fait leur pc avait un problème ils nous ont demandé de les
envoyer pour eux
N'hésitez pas à faire appel à moi ! Je couvre toute sorte d'infractions, n'hésitez pas ! Du coup, Quentin et moi, on s'est mangé une semaine
d'exclusion c'est hyper c'est une sanction de ouf au collège quand t'es exclu une semaine c'est vraiment a fait un truc mais de ouf
Ah bah là juste envoyer un mail
gentil, ha ha ! Mais j'ai fini par foufoune et ça avait vraiment.. Ma prof de maths j'vous assure était vraiment choquée et je crois qu'elle a même vu
un psy derrière et tous alors que mec le mail n'y avait rien de ouf
quoi
c'est
incroyable ! Et voilà les amis, c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo. Je voulais trop vous racontez tout ça parce que c'est ce qui me reste comme souvenir de
mon adolescence il ya plein de trucs j'ai oublié la plupart des trucs je les ai oublié mais ça je m'en souviens parce que ça m'a vraiment
marqué et ça m'a marqué pour une bonne raison c'est que c'est assez n'importe quoi finalement donc j'espère que ça vous aura fait marrer passe
un bon moment je vous dis à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo j'ai extrêmement soif j'ai fait que de parler pour toutes les vidéos
voilà j'ai la pâteuse, mes lèvres sont en train de se dissoudre. Allez à vous tous dans une prochaine vidéo ! Portez vous bien et n'oubliez pas
Ne faites pas de pétard dans un parc fermé
ricanement un peut drole (mais pas trop)
music d'outro